you were a bartender and i just loved
the idea you would be
such a good bartender marco floyd thank
you generously
don't you know he'd do a generous pour
he would always ask for awkwardness
i i i would do it generally yeah mostly
because people would be like come on man
really but no but didn't you you had
your own cocktail
i had the margarita
and what are you doing with ruffalo but
no margarita
but i ended up having uh you know i'd
start early and i'd had my
my thursday night crowd yeah partially
because
and i'm sorry sean mcpherson wherever
you are
i gave away a lot of free drinks
it wasn't a great quality in a bartender
but you were good
dealing with with uh drunk customers
which is a i had to deal with a lot of
drunk people yes
and um sometimes they were not very nice
no there'd be nights where i'd be up to
my eyeballs and a-holes
um i'm saying nothing
can i keep going i don't know what's
going to mean
wait what what did i say nothing is that
a spoiler
no no it's nothing marvel you're calling
me no
no no so no wasn't there a guy who
wanted
uh was there a drunkard oh i get it yeah
wasn't there a drunk guy it wasn't that
kind of bar
was there drunk guy who wanted uh
sambuca yes there was okay so tell us
about him so
occasionally um you would get someone
who was so obnoxious
and uh it was the end of the night and
this guy came in
and he's like and he was wasted and he
was such an a-hole
and uh he's like i want a zambuka
i'm like come on man you you're doing
okay
you're like give me a zambooka
and did he hit his knee like that
i thought yeah give me a zamboca i'm
like okay so i
pour on the sambuca light
i'm not going to let you drink man i
don't like drinks
okay you want to let your drink you let
you drink yourself light it
okay i light the drink
he takes it and it goes
all over his face dripping down his face
blue flames everywhere
and i'm trying not to laugh
and he
beats the hell out of himself to get it
out
give me another
sure thing you want me to light it for
you
yes same thing
[Applause]
it was one of the greatest nights
i sort of like him for having another
one
i love him he walked out with like uh
like a
a flaming red goatee
that brings back a really painful memory
it was you
no
that would be amazing
i was like 12 13. i
i i was late i was a late bloomer but i
had a premature mustache
like i had i had hair there and nowhere
else right
i mean my head of course and uh
and i was begging my dad because kids
were making fun of me like oh you're
stash swimmer you must
you know and so i was begging my dad hey
can i please shave and my dad was like
you're too young to shave i'm sorry
but i was i took matters into my own
hand
and i borrowed some of my sister's nair
oh no
and for those of you who don't know it's
like a chemical hair removal
if we go to immaculate immaculate okay
so i put it on my lip but i left it on
too long
so i had a burn mark
just like a guy just like that only
i it was you know i had to then go to
school and everyone knew i had tried
to take my hair up and they're like what
the
so all these other names so i'm sorry to
bring up that
that trauma but i want to share that
very good
comic book heroes and action films we
kind of assume
they appeal to kind of nerdy boys
essentially yeah
and you kind of forget there are lots of
nerdy women out there
who like these films yeah i think
everyone's got their inner nerd
yeah well you are a proper nerd aren't
you i mean when it comes to harry potter
i'm a massive massive nerd
we know that because you posted this
book is this your 12th or you're about
12 or 13 here
this is margot robbie look how uncool
hardback hardback harry potter
no you're a real fan so fancy do you
know what's particularly pathetic about
this picture
a couple things really um number one
i'll let you point them out
number one it's my birthday that's how i
chose to spend my birthday
what was in a cup uh number two i'm
drinking tea
uh number three i'm wearing glasses even
though i don't need glasses i lied to
the optometrist because i wanted to have
glasses like that
now daniel i think you were were you a
harry potter fan and i love harry potter
i just to get round to reading the last
one
okay so i just i was i have stuff to do
mum
i was getting i don't know what happened
i was just like i'll do it later on then
are you kidding me so you've read one to
six and you haven't read the seven yeah
i don't know are you actually kidding
me couldn't bear for twins i'm not going
to be able to sleep tonight worrying
about this
life is a game you mean
i just like it's just you keep it on the
edge i mean this is insane to me
do you know another fun fact my husband
is your thing this is fascinating
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so i'll stop hijacking the show after
this because i'm not here to
publicize harry potter um
my husband is in the harry potter movies
i know
i was like had you told me cena we would
have been married very quickly but he
was
an extra he was like when he was a
little kid he's like one of the
slaughtering
extras you know when draco like pushes
some kids out of the way to
to see buckbeak in the third book yeah
he pushes my husband out of the way
[Applause]
yeah i know were you ever an extra in
harry potter
no no someone i had a my friend was an
extra
at school then i asked him like how did
you get into acting and he didn't tell
me
because you posted a picture of yourself
no you posted a picture of yourself
as i don't know how old you are you're a
little boy here and uh you look like you
could be
in hogwarts here you are good
you showed me that when we were filming
i love that i feel better about my photo
now
yeah i know people you went to school
with must be so surprised
who's a film star daniel
and what a time to be in london ladies
and gentlemen these people have been
going
mark on our capital patrick stewart have
you been to
pickard dilly station
no have you seen this i mean yeah people
have they've rebranded it
this is real they've made piccadilly
station pick our dilly
circus uh it's pretty cool it is i mean
it's him but they've also done it on
the um subway in manhattan except that
they've drawn an imaginary line between
five stations so that it looks like that
thing that we wear
and i don't know why oh i got it the
star trek logo thing
yeah i think so there are five stations
on the subway
not as good not as good uh
now uh michael george j parks you've
been in town for a few days yeah we've
been here for
yeah you've been out and about enjoying
yourselves yeah out you know reading
scriptures and
spreading the word you've been to the
club a couple of times
yeah i've seen the pictures um
because michael would you go out and
about because uh chadwick boseman from
black panther he was here a little while
ago
and i feel like maybe he's a little over
wakanda forever now
uh but like you never never really got
that i think the fans kind of understand
that the eric killmonger wasn't
really with wakanda all the way so they
kind of respect me but
no we're not going to say what kind of
boy so good come on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and i like the way people are finding
different things to do in in
lockdown you know home fitness
and meditation you've gone the booze
route
is that true maybe yes yes yes
yes cocktails in the afternoon do you
post your
um mixology every day or just when the
mood takes you
no no just from the just when i'm not
too drunk
to work my phone is when i do it no when
i we
we're just sort of doing it periodically
every every every week or so something
like that
well people are loving them we've got
some tweets here
uh who knew stanley tucci making a
negroni was my kink
here's somebody else i want stanley
tucci to manhandle me the way he slams
down his cocktail ingredients
and uh that was my agent no i'm kidding
and even chris evans chris evans posted
this i love
stanley tucci on some most days after he
finished filming on the first captain
america movie stanley would make his
martinis in his trailer
would you do that every day the the
martini yeah
yeah yeah i always have a i like to have
a portable uh
cocktail set that i i bring to set and
at the end of the day
if if it's the appropriate time we uh
we make martinis for whoever would like
to join me
that is such a lovely thing that's nice
you know it's
civilized very civilized uh now miriam
margulies is this it now have you been
banned from daytime television
well i said or and apparently
it's one of the worst things you can say
is it yeah but they sent me a list of
the things
and you memorized it well
one of the words on it was one i had
never heard of i don't know if you have
what was it it was
munter have you ever heard of that word
m-u-n-t-e-r yeah
i don't know where it originates from
but i think it means an unattractive
woman or i didn't know it was oh i think
it can be i think it could be
i think it can be both yeah i've never
heard of that well has anybody heard it
in the audience
oh wow a lovely crowd
i guess we've all been called what was
out what was the tv show
it was called this morning
[Applause]
whenever you're on the show i always ask
you about uh thor's hammer
and you always say oh that's in my house
in australia you're in your house in
australia
uh do you have the hammer is it really
there oh the hammer you mean the
this one yeah oh
very impressive half the time i don't
even you know i sort of forget where i
put them i don't really have them
that that that close to me and so it's
you know i've got sawn breaker
i just happened to turn up here the
avengers this
small object yeah
they go everywhere with me basically